thank you very much for coming good
morning my name is Mike Gorham I'm here
to talk about progressive web apps and
offline development just a little bit
about me
so I'm a full-stack developer working
lamp and node I run something called
Maiden Academy which is a training
company in bath in the UK basically I
learn new stuff and then I come to
conferences and teach other people it so
today as I said we're talking about
progressive web apps so what is a
progressive web app if you go to
Wikipedia it says this progressive web
apps are experiences that combine the
best of the web and the best of the apps
which sounds great but doesn't really
tell us the massive amount about what it
actually is from a practical perspective
so that's what we're going to look at so
progressive web apps first kind of the
concept came around in an article
written by Alex Russell in 2015 where he
was talking about native applications
versus web applications and in this
article he talked about how the
progressive web app should appear like a
native application on your mobile device
that they possibly could work offline
and that they should be operating system
agnostic now we're not quite there yet
the support is getting better but if
you're on the latest versions of Windows
Android iOS or OSX then you can use this
it's just not fully feature supported
which we're going to look at a little
bit but the crux of it is that these
days a PWA or a progressive web app is
basically just your web application the
apps that you've already got that run by
the browser with a little bit of extra
JavaScript to make it do some cool
things and that's what we're going to
look at
the idea behind a PWA is that at the
moment with a native app you have to if
you want to use an app you have to go to
an app store download the app wait for
it to install then open it and start
using it if you haven't already got it
of course the idea with a PWA is that
this is kind of flipped on its head and
rather than having to install an
application first before you can start
using it you just go to a URL and you
start using the web version of that
application and it will just install
silently in the background so that the
next time you come back it's quick and
it's ready to use and it works like a
native application we can have a look at
that basically in order to trigger the
PWA install in the background you have
to be considered what Google coin as a
regular user now how they consider or
they consider regular users if you visit
a your app or an application at least
twice with at least five minutes in
between now I don't have regular that
actually makes you but that's for them
that's the current definition so what
that actually means is you go to the URL
like this
it loads any normal browser and it
triggers that pop-up click install and
on your home screen you'll get a icon up
here like a native application you can
then click that icon and it'll open the
same page that you were on previously
but in the full full screen standalone
mode is what they call it so just to see
that again it's quite quick animation
there so no URL bar looks like a full
application
sorry that's quite quick basically
allows you to treat that application
from that point onwards like a native
app on the phone now this one doesn't
have a defined icon but we'll look at
later how you can actually change the
icon so that you don't get a the the
chrome icons to actually get your
standard whatever icon you want so why
do we want this why why is Peter view a
good thing let's have a look at some
some case studies tinder were one of the
first big applications to to do this
they obviously have quite a popular
mobile app when they turned their online
version into a PWA then web version into
a PWA they actually cut their load times
from eleven point nine one seconds on
their native app down to four point six
nine seconds which is a reasonable
increase in speed the their pwl is
actually ninety percent smaller than the
native android application
how about uber so we've done the same
and theirs is only 50 K when gzipped
this means that if you're traveling and
using uber in a somewhere that you're
not familiar with where maybe you don't
have 4G then now actually can load the
you burst PWA in less than three seconds
even on a 2g network which is very
important if you're you know lost
somewhere you
trivago have also done this so it's not
just about speed it's also about user
engagement true Vargo's app actually
wasn't all that popular because people
don't just want an apps out on their
phone that they're only going to use a
couple of times year when they go on
holiday but people often use their they
have a high user engagement on their
actual website particularly for mobile
so by by implementing their PWA they
increase their user engagement versus
their native application by a hundred
and fifty percent
this obviously resulted in higher higher
and that have clicks through to the
hotel offers ninety seven percent
increase and actually also came with
offline support and they found that 67%
when their users are still browsing
their application when offline so
they're not losing users as soon as the
internet drops out okay last one
Pinterest have implemented the PWA to
their user engagement increased by about
sixty percent this resulted in a forty
four percent increase in user generated
revenue from ads and ultimately the
amount of time spent using Pinterest has
gone up by about 40 percent so we've got
some pretty good case studies as to why
we should be doing pwace so how how do
we do a PW how do we convert so actually
you need three things to for your
application to be considered the PWA
I've got four on there because it made
my slide symmetrical so you need HTTPS
but you're already doing that obviously
you need a serviceworker which is a bit
like a client-side proxy and we can have
a look at that in a minute
and you need a web app web app manifest
file this is a JSON file that allows you
to configure your PWA settings basically
look at that to know the last one you
didn't actually need to be considered
the PWA but you probably want to be
using it anyway so we'll have a look at
that too a little bit so what is the web
app manifest as I said it's a JSON file
you link to it in the head of your HTML
just using the rel equals manifest and
then the location of your JSON file
inside your JSON file it allows you to
basically specify all of the things all
of the settings that your users see when
they launch your application so that's
the default background color of your
splash screen whilst it's loading it's
the icon that gets installed on their
home screen is the name of the
application that gets installed on your
home screen
it's the Europe the initial URL that
will open when they click on the icon
from their home screen
it's how the application will open when
they when they first click on it so the
gift that I showed you earlier was using
display of stand alone so open with no
URL bar and the device treated like a
standalone application but actually
that's that's optional you can have it
open in your browser or standalone and
there's a whole list of different
settings that you can put in your web
app manifest these are basically the
ones that you want there are a load of
other ones that give you a lot of
control
some it's easy so how about the Service
Worker so as I said this is a
client-side proxy it runs in a separate
execution thread from your standard
JavaScript and so when block your normal
JavaScript from running it doesn't have
any Dom access which when you first
start to do this you'll think is a real
pain and then you kind of realize what
you're supposed to do with
serviceworkers and realize that you
probably don't need it anyway
but there is a new API called the post
message I say new it's not that new but
call the post message API which allows
you to pass messages from your
serviceworker back to your standard
JavaScript front-end so that your
JavaScript can then pick those up
it's event-based
and then update your UI basically your
PWA has the ability to interact with all
your network requests so any HTTP
request or response your your service
worker has access to to that request and
response and can manipulate it and
interact with it it's most commonly used
for cache management but we can do a lot
more with it so in order to implement a
Service Worker it's actually really easy
you just need basically this bit of
JavaScript in the head of your of your
page
generally the advice because this is so
small is to actually just put this
straight in the head rather than linking
it from a separate file so it loads
straight away you don't have to do it
and did it an additional request to get
it basically we just check if service
workers exist in the current browser
obviously they're not fully supported if
they do exist
then we specify the file of where our
service worker is we give it a scope
which is how much of the current domain
that that service worker has control
over so by giving mine the scope of
forward slash means I can control
everything and then we registered that
and we catch any errors just in case
there's a there's a problem okay
now inside the Service Worker file sorry
so yeah that's literally it that's
actually registered to Service Worker
and actually technically as far as
Google and everybody is concerned if you
if your Service Worker file is actually
empty but you've registered one provided
you've got a web app manifest file and
you're running over HTTP then you've
made a PWA you're done you actually
don't have to make your so I could do
anything probably don't do that but in
theory
so let's actually make our service
worker do something
so inside the Service Worker itself it's
as I said its event based so we hook
into the install event and then here we
can we can can control what's happening
so all I'm doing here is I'm using the
caching API
to open the new cache and then just
store a CSS file in it this means that
from now on any request that goes to my
adult CSS file will pull it out of my
cache instead which is quite nice
as I said this is the most common usage
for a for a serviceworker we're gonna
look at some other things so as I said
it can it has access to all of your all
of your network requests all of your
HTTP traffic so here I'm hooking into
the fetch event which is the name for an
HTTP request or an ajax request these
days who used to using the fetch API
this will hook into every or any HTTP
request that comes out of your
application and then allows you to
decide what happens with that so in this
one I'm just checking whether it's in my
cache and if it is then I'm gonna get it
out of my cache and send it back and if
it's not then I'll actually do my fetch
request
so that's controlling HTTP requests and
using caching which as I said it's the
most common usage but we can actually we
can do it we can do a bit more with this
so here we've got I've got an example of
only pulling data actually back from the
server
if the data is stale now I've decided in
my day to go to still after five minutes
so no matter how many times somebody
requests some data from the server if
the last request sorry if the last time
that I got the data from the server was
over five minutes ago then it'll go and
get it if it's less than five minutes
ago then it will just pull out my cache
so earlier we were catching files but
actually you don't have to you can catch
anything so if you're pulling data back
from a JSON API for example then you can
just put that in your cache and save
that for later so the next time somebody
does a request if you already got the
data
and it hasn't yet changed then you can
just pull it straight out the cache and
not actually bother going to the servers
this works with any Ajax request neh
people request whether you're using the
fetch API or whether you're using sorry
excuse me
whether you're using XML HTTP requests
as well will still work so basically
what's going on here is the initial
request to your API goes out gets the
data on its way back we'd store the data
and then we display it to the user user
interacts with your page in some way
they refresh or they get to another page
which requires the same data on it the
request goes out but this time the
service worker picks it up and the
decides how to respond with it so we
already got that data if so let's just
respond with the data from our cache
if not then it'll go and get it again
from the server that responds and your
front-end knows no difference as far as
its concerned your your your fetch
request has come back as standard and
then you can update your your UI your
Dom have you have you see fit so the bit
that I'd like to look at is the the
storing data at the moment I talked
about the cache API but that's not the
only way of storing data on the front
end so we can have a look at that in a
bit more detail so there's basically
three three places on the front end all
three things that we can use to store
data
there's the cache API which I mentioned
this is generally used for caching files
but it can be used to cache data that
and it'll store is just plain text
that's not ideal if we're storing Jason
particularly for storing large amounts
of data for storing JSON or XML and we
want there's no way of querying you just
to pull it and pull the whole thing out
so other alternatives there's the local
storage API the html5 local storage this
is really popular because I mean it's
the first like client-side storage
facility to come out and it's
synchronous so it's really easy to use
you don't
worry about callbacks or promises or
anything like that but actually because
it's synchronous it doesn't work with
the serviceworker so you can't use it so
if you're already using in local storage
on your application unfortunately you
can't use that from your serviceworker
it just doesn't work so the alternative
is indexeddb which is an asynchronous
equivalent almost it's generally used
for storing extremely large amounts of
data or large amounts of data extremely
it may be a bit over the top but it's
really efficient for doing
high-performance searches you don't have
to pull everything out because it
doesn't actually store its plain text it
stores key value pairs and they actually
indexes your data so it's basically
basically just like a front-end database
but in your users browser so you can
pull the data from there very quickly so
as I said it's it's a client-side
storage it's designed for large amounts
of data it's usually jacent but it
doesn't have to be kind of store pretty
much anything you want in there it uses
indexes for performance it's
asynchronous because it's based on the
promise API and it's actually a
permanent data storage so that that's
one of the things that people often
don't get when I talk about index to DB
is that actually you user can leave and
then come back and the dates are still
there
it won't expire at all it's not like a
cookie or there's no expiration on it
unless you delete it or they uninstall
the browser or they go in via the dev
tools and actually when it related
themselves
the data will disappear it's it's
permanent storage as I said it's pretty
quick so depending on your device it
tops out about 1k reads per second
writes depends on the amount of data
you're writing so currently B stats on
that but it's not as quick as reading
generally it's much much faster than
doing a network request to back-end for
a small and medium sized data obviously
there's no overhead there's no waiting
for the internet for large amounts of
data it varies depending on what you're
doing
so how do we use
indexdb it's actually pretty easy in any
browser which supports it which these
days is all of the modern ones we simply
open a new database we open a
transaction
give it a database name this one is
called to-do list we give it the
permissions that we want so read write
and then we open an object store which
is like a table from your database from
once you've done that you've then
basically just got a connection to your
to your database table and you can start
adding stuff
so here I've just added an object or
they keep adding pair of my name and now
just store in this example store some
JSON with the key of one so as I said
it's indexed then we can get it back out
by just calling get with the key and
it'll give me the data it does do auto
indexing as well it water increment your
index so you can just leave that one off
and it'll just do it for you and then
you can update using put so here I've
just changed my name is charlie and
updated the key of one so if we come
back and have a look at the code that we
saw earlier where we were doing a
network request if the date had gone
stale after five minutes this time
rather than storing anything in the
cache we're just going to put it in it
into index DB using the ID from the
request and then if the if the date is
there then we can get it out and if it's
not then we can go to the server fetch
it and put in and store it
okay so that's just some other things
that we can do with with our
serviceworker and actually now that
we've started to store data in the on
the client side we've almost basically
achieved offline development the fetch
request doesn't go to the server you
know can pull data straight out of your
browser your application will work
offline but there's some more stuff that
we want to do with this so the first
thing you need to take into
consideration when you're doing this
offline development is the UX
implications for your application for
your app should you be doing offline if
you're building something like a finance
app that's tracking stock market prices
you probably don't want to be caching
that data for five minutes people quite
a long way out a date oh train times for
example if it's a live train up then you
definitely don't want to be caching it
but if it's looking at stuff for
tomorrow then five minutes maybe not too
bad but definitely think about your UX
the UX implications of working offline
and whether you know that's actually a
good thing for your users my big bit of
advice for this is to make sure that you
update your UI so tell your users that
they are offline
they might know of realized and I've
seen quite a lot of these applications
where they've got offline support and
then they don't actually show a message
or show any notification to tell their
users that they're no longer connected
and the data they're seeing is not
necessarily not necessarily the latest
so use the post message API that I
mentioned earlier and actually tell your
users they're not in like we're gonna
have a look at that
so from inside your serviceworker we can
actually detect whether you're online or
not this bit in bold here is doing is
doing an effect request that's the bit
that's actually going to the internet so
we need to we're going to drill down
into that a little bit more now this
code gets quite long so I've just
commented it rather than actually
providing the code for you so you can
see the principles but basically we do a
fetch request
if the request fails then we catch the
request in here the error will contain a
message that'll say that you're the
network is unavailable so you can check
that and if the network's unavailable
then we can do something about it so
maybe we would try and pull it back out
of indexdb where we stored it earlier
and then update the UI or whatever the
relevant thing to do when they're
offline is now we can also do without
without your service work then you can
also now update the front-end using a
new flag inside the navigator object
called is called online this is just a
bulid that will return whether the
device is currently connected to the
internet or not it will basically just
say true if you're connected and false
if you're not there's also two new
events called online and offline which
fire on the window when that when the
status of your connectivity changes so
we can hook into these events the online
and the offline events and this one just
updates a very simple deer for whatever
in the page you just show the users that
they're no longer connected this can be
done without the serviceworker at all so
even if they're not making fetch
requests if they're just scrolling
through a page that already exists this
will just update without them actually
having to refresh or go to a different
page they'll instantly get a
notification they'll will say you're not
connected anymore so we can come back to
this slide so we're doing our initial
request to our API goes and gets the
data store it in index DB and we display
the perform the user then performs a
page action like a page refresh or
changes pages that to a page requires
the same data the serviceworker kicks in
and performs a fetch request or falls
back to indexeddb if the network is down
and pull this data back out of the cache
and then your front-end code then just
update the UI as if it had data back
from a standard request so service work
has also come with this thing called
background sync this is actually really
useful for flow in development and I
strongly suggest using this if you're
gonna do the stuff that I just talked
about so I had to kind of squeeze all my
code onto one slide here so it's a
little bit condensed but the top bit is
sort of your application so here I've
got an event listener on a button when
we click the button it's gonna make an
AJAX request to update my train times or
whatever and rather than doing a
standard fetch I'm actually using the
background sync API to register this
event called update trains that sync
event will can then be picked up inside
your serviceworker where you can hook
into the tag name in my case update
trains and that you can use is this
thing called wait until event wait until
and it will cool that function as soon
as you're connected so it will just sit
and wait whilst you're offline and then
as soon as your connectivity comes back
it will make the request for you so you
could do that based on the button click
like I have you could do that in the
event called sorry in the event callback
when as soon as your application goes
offline from the front-end detection and
it will just sit and wait in the
background whilst whilst your users not
online and then as soon as they come
back as soon as the connectivity comes
back it will make that request the
promise will resolve and you can update
your front-end
so I've talked all about the things that
you can do and the and the good things
about pwace so what are the limitations
well it varies between operating system
and end device but at the moment there
is a 50 megabyte limit on iOS for the
amount of data that you can store that's
a hard limit and it's a complete limit
so it's not just files that's data in
indexdb that's it's everything you have
a maximum limit of 51 yeah yeah Purdue
me okay
on Android last time I checked it was 2
gigabytes but they keep changing it but
it's probably more than you need
iOS also has this Auto delete link which
they think is really useful but it's
probably really annoying basically if
you don't use the PWA for a couple of
weeks
iOS will just delete it it won't
actually delete the icon from your
homescreen that stay there so as far as
the user is concerned nothing's actually
happened but in the in the background
all the files the cache the indexdb data
everything just gets removed so the next
time that they open it it will then
redownload everything which isn't a big
problem but it doesn't mean that if they
haven't used it for a couple of weeks
that the first load will be a lot slower
it has to go and Bri download everything
and it means that you have to take this
into consideration because your first
load needs to check whether they've got
stuff that they need you can't just pull
it straight out of index DB if it's been
deleted
now there is a talk in the next slot
about the mobile web api the browser API
stuff so I'm not going to talk about
that too much but that stuff is still
under development it's really cool it
does give you a lot of power but there's
there's there's some limitations from
PwC
particularly from service workers so
your service work it doesn't have access
basically to most of these features at
the moment that does vary depending on
your device but things like Bluetooth
and your touch ID so your fingerprint
scanning your face facial scanner that
kind of stuff your service worker can't
access any of that stuff so if it needs
access to any of that data you have to
pass it to and from using the post
message and accessing it from your from
your front-end iOS it doesn't have
access to push notifications or any Siri
integration on Android you actually
can't access the Google home assistant
and use push notifications but not not
on iOS so what does this what does this
mean for you
well first thing is to brush up on your
JavaScript probably I had to don't bend
your native application just yet
but maybe soon it'd be nice if one day
in the future we don't have to maintain
too good code bases and we can just have
one web application which will work
across the board but I don't think we're
quite there yet but it's still worth
implementing now and then possibly one
day we will be able to get rid of native
applications altogether
ultimately the big thing that it means
for all of us is that there's less HTTP
requests there's gonna be less traffic
coming from your front end to your back
end because we can catch stuff and we
can control what's happening on the
front end a lot more obviously there's
all the UX implications that I talked
about earlier but the main benefit of
this is that maybe we'll need some other
servers or we'll have to worry about
less traffic
it's only a good thing so some resources
for you sorry
service work dot RS website has a whole
bunch of they're not tutorials they're
literally just code samples of all the
different things that you might want to
be able to do with the Service Worker so
you can just this is literally a screen
show up the page you just go there and
down the left hand side there's just all
these different things that you might
want to be able to do caching different
kinds of caching different on a network
background sync stuff basically all the
stuff I've talked about today click on
any of them and it will give you the
code for how to do it very a very simple
introduction to really great visuals PWA
stats comm this is where all of my stats
from today have come from it's basically
just a whole list of testimonials or
case studies of applications that have
implemented PWA and then the difference
is that they found so you can go and
read up about it because there's
actually quite a lot of them now so
thank you very much
[Applause]